So now that we have seen how function inlining works,
let's do function inlining quiz. So let's say we have a load into A 0,
which would be the first argument of a function. And then we call a function,
and then we store the result of the function somewhere else. Let's say
that what the function is doing is it's computing the square of this value, and
then adding the second parameter to it, and that's what it returns. So it's
simply returning the, you know, square of the first parameter plus the second
parameter. Let's say we have a processor where load takes 2 cycles to do,
CALL takes 2 cycles to do, RET takes 2 cycles to do, and Store Word and
ADD are one cycle per instruction. And the multiply instruction takes 3 cycles
before we can use the result. The question for you is, after scheduling this and
this together will take how many cycles? So how many cycles from the point we
start to load, until we are done with the store. And after inlining and
then scheduling, how many cycles does this take?